1200 m² partis en fumée une vingtaine de
voitures calcinées
c'est la scène d'horreur qu'ont
découvert les employés du garage
bulliard l'atelier de peinture de cette
institution de l'automobile est
totalement des trucs plus bombée
qu'autre chose et puis des fonds d quand
j'ai lu ça mais si c'est pas possible je
croyais que c'était un désastre
économique pour cette gérante car
l'entreprise est fragile valérie coop
est à relancer cette société il y a
trois ans après sa liquidation
judiciaire elle était quand même assez
fragile économiquement et nous
constatons que nous avons tous à refaire
sur tout nouveau la peinture après tout
c'est quand même le dernier le dernier
acte profits dans donne à tous les deux
dans un garage et sakai met à mal
l'activité forte heureusement seul
l'atelier de peinture est touché alors
si certains bleus déjà à la relance de
l'entreprise
la plupart des 32 employés ont été mis
en congé mais c'est sans compter sur la
solidarité dans le secteur certains
confrères sont pris à mettre leur
atelier de peinture à disposition des
techniciens de la société
aujourd'hui j'arrive là donc avec des
propositions sivadier consulter qui
certains garages de proximité qui sont
déjà prêts à les accompagner tab au
niveau personnel pour éviter le chômage
technique est au niveau de la
productivité de la barre hâtive peinture
qui une coopération qui permettra la
réouverture du garage le 26 décembre
prochain
parallèlement une enquête est en cours
afin de déterminer les causes de
l'incendié
pour confirmer ou écarté la piste
criminelle